Scott you reviewed 2 zombie games last
week we'll get to the plants later on
that didn't even click didn't I brain
that they realize technically zombie
games wow that's weird that I never put
those two together yeah you're exactly
right yeah you didn't realize you were
hired as our zombie enthusiast parent
thing well in my defense they're
extremely different games I mean pvz is
obviously like very like cute and funny
and damn friendly dying light is very
like it's bleak especially like for
anybody that's finished the dlc like you
know exactly how bleak it gets it's
pretty intense but they're both they're
both great for different reasons I
really enjoy both of them on head yeah
the following got an 8 out of 10 yes but
an interesting-looking expansion I
remember a couple months ago they like
put the price up because they'd been
like adding so much to it and so it's
1999 now it's like a fully fledged kind
of like almost feels like a standalone
thing very different what they've done
they've you know for a game about
parkour it's they're basically in the
middle of the countryside yeah it's so
like the for anybody that didn't play
the original it was based primary line
like a pork or traversal system it was
you know weapon crafting in zombie
killing and parkour and now this DLC is
hey you have a customizable buggy and
can just drive around the countryside
which feels like the antithesis Oh
parkouring through buildings and stuff
so kind of a weird design decision which
is why it's kind of amazing that it
works so well like not not only do the
driving mechanics themselves actually
function beautifully it melds with the
existing gameplay really well i mean it
builds on the existing weapon crafting
system so like that all feels very
familiar um it's it all just kind of
works in a way and it ends up being
super fun so what's it like you sort of
church I guess you need to have a good
driving model for a game that's gonna be
set outside the wilderness what's it
like traversing that big open area
what's the bug if you like and there's
like upgrades in one lafaard as well
yeah that's actually sort of the best
part so to be clear dining light is not
a standalone it has enough content that
it could have been yeah but it is an
expansion to the existing game so you
carry all everything that you earn in
the original game into the DLC so that
means that if you play to the end of
dying light you're pretty much all the
way leveled up so the nice thing about
the DLC is it gives you this new skill
tree to level up to have something to
work towards and that skill tree is your
buggy so you're earning upgrades you're
adding sup to it you're like equipping
it with flamethrowers and UV headlights
which stuns
these things like that so that whole
process of building up your buggy super
satisfying but it also maintains the
sort of survival elements of like you
have to go out and scavenge for gas and
scavenger parts and you know your buggy
will deteriorate the more you drive it
you have to keep it running so again
that's part of why it all melts together
and work so well with the existing
experience so yeah upgrades awesome
limped overs awesome it's it's weird cuz
i was playing Mad Max over the holiday
break and I also play half life 2
basically every year and this kind of
felt like I played a little bit of this
and it felt like the highway 17 levels
of half-life to mix with this like like
you're yeah like you're saying
collecting all this research absolutely
I was actually talking with somebody I
think that was even a line in the review
at one point that I ended up getting cut
that it's sort of a better Mad Max than
Matt Matt I am because it actually has
like the survival elements and the
satisfaction of building up the car and
making your own is actually sort of
better than it was in the Mad Max game
which was not a terrible game but it's
yeah this DLC kind of nails it without
really necessarily aiming for that it
just kind of like I said fits with the
existing experience and just becomes mad
max on accident yeah a game do you loved
that was actually the very firm lobby I
ever watch because I've already being
like oh yeah Peter Brown guys got a good
head and shoulders feel bad cuz everyone
in the comments hates him that was i
I've since gone back and played my Maxis
I haven't played my max you gave a tick
6 out of 10 yeah like I'm I'm totally
with you but like it's it's a totally
competent game that's like ah it looks
it looks really pretty the driving was
really fun but the sort of stuff you're
describing about the buggy which should
be this sort of like organic
relationship with your cars you really
grow attached to it the game like forced
objectives through forced upgrades right
so you were like I have to upgrade my
buggy this way or that way to continue
the story and it just felt so prescribed
and clinical it was like I don't know
and even the resource gathering in Mad
Max was not that imperative to your
success and I found yeah you know
whatever I mean it's it's cool to see
that dying Led did so well especially I
is it's so different and they've even
said now that in 2016 they're gonna make
more content for the game right because
the following has just done so well for
them yeah it should I mean it's one of
my favorite pieces of DLC like maybe
ever it's just because it does something
that's both knew I mean the way phrased
interviews it's both it's at once
distinct from and in sync with the
original experience I think
that's what makes it so impressive yeah
that it does something new and it works
and it feels natural like all of those
elements combined or something that's
just fun like driving around and mowing
down zombies like I don't really know
what more you could want a DLC yeah LC
usually just like adds something to you
know a sort of a base game that's like
just complimentary almost all right fits
in really neatly whereas this almost
seems like they just have this whole
idea a different game or just like screw
it let's just do this and it works I
mean it wasn't perfect he still got an 8
out of 10 but no I mean I highly
recommend it at a 10 in my mind is like
an excellent score what was the combat
like considering like this was a game
that was based around melee yeah but
like a really difficult sort of you know
in dying light when you use weapons they
break apart especially to start when you
haven't sort of upgraded your your
characters ability to like durability of
the weapons like stuff falls apart
really quickly what's it like suddenly
having a card you can basically just mow
down zombies in well like I said so the
car does break down too so you're not
completely off the hook like the more
the more you drive off road and the more
zombies you hit like things will just
start to fall apart until to the point
then eventually your buggy will just
like not be drivable anymore if you're
not repairing it actively so it doesn't
make the game like too easy doesn't
really break the game and in really the
new setting kind of changes the way you
have to approach combat because you're
right in the original game it was very
male a focused you were very up close
and personal and in this having so much
space it means both not having cover
anymore not having a convenient means of
escape you can't just like climb up on a
van and like be above the fray and find
a way out you know you actually have no
choice but to engage the zombies that
are after you or to like get your buggy
and run so it does change the way you
approach combats you end up using range
weapons a lot more you absolutely just
great tactical crossbow you get as you
play through the DLC that's phenomenal
but also if you still have any firearms
from the original game does work great I
highly recommend them they're much safer
than trying to melee like a huge horde
of zombies that you can't get away from
anymore so yeah it fundamentally changes
the way you approach combat without
actually doing any like introducing any
new combat mechanics right which is
another reason that I think the DLC
works so well yeah it's really quite an
achievement I thanks step one who's been
sending in questions via the chat yes as
you can see the folks in the [ __ ] he
was throwing up all your questions so
please by all means got them in their
apt on your door if you want me to see
them here on my laptop
as well let's talk briefly about what I
getting too much into the story of stuff
how is the story does a payoff yeah i
mean i've seen some common so i don't
want to spoil the ending because it
really goes in like a pretty pretty
gnarly direction a lot of people really
hated it I I admire that they made a
bold choice with the way they wrap it up
but the sort of the premise is Tom's
president at the end yes right it's
terrifying zombie Donald trivia here no
so Donald Trump some speaking of brains
um let's see Oh cold yeah so the basic
premise is at the end at the end of
dying light from he hasn't finished it
like you're still in a city overrun with
zombies like I won't spoil how that game
wraps up but at end of the game like
you're still in a city there are still
zombies so this DLC starts with a random
person from outside of town showing up
being like hey there's a way out and by
the way there's also a place where
people are immune to this epidemic okay
I'm gonna die now and then he dies we're
yeah and you take his map and find your
way out and then you're suddenly in the
countryside and you discover that
there's like this whole cold situation
and you have to infiltrate the cult to
try to figure out how people are like
immune to the zombie virus and you have
like standing with them oh yeah you
basically have to earn their trust
because they're very mistrustful of
outsiders they don't know who you are
they don't you know want to reveal
anything to you and of course like the
the whole rabbit hole of this cold the
whole conspiracy goes very deep and so
you just peel back you know the onion
layers but so that does mean and this is
one my biggest problems with the DLC
actually you end up doing a lot of just
fetch quests as favors there I'm trust
it's like oh gee whiz I don't want to
tell you about this thing so why don't
you go talk to this guy and the opposite
side of the map for no reason ah so
there's a lot of that which is
unfortunate but in terms of narrow to
pay off it does actually work like it's
annoying having to do so many fetch
quests but at least there's a compelling
reason to do them and like there is sort
of payoff and it does kind of go
somewhere and I appreciate that it
becomes a conspiracy thriller rather
than just a generic you know oh there
are zombies we have to kill them survive
you know like every other zombie game so
it's a pretty novel approach for an
apocalypse style setting which is cool I
was thinking be great if there's a
zombie game where you had to try your
best to actually get bitten but the
zombies just don't anything to do with
you secretly going out of your way like
zombie dating cinnamon yeah except
driver every time you try and knock
somebody down they just go
and before we wrap this up I got some
questions from the jock coming in here
yeah mammoth EU saying at dying light
the following is exactly what the ELC
should look like such great value for
money it is 1999 I know it's 60 bucks
with the base game as well they're
selling yeah so actually there's a
special edition like definitive edition
of the entire game you can buy for sixty
dollars which does include the following
DLC so if you never play the original
that's probably your best bet because
you can upgrade and play through the
original game and carry all that into
the DLC and it's all in one convenient
package cool a shooty 78 says how long
is the following because name is Xu d7
beauty 78 that's awesome I guess he like
shooters he's truth 38 years 30
something years old oh yeah yeah man
yeah we're editor Sweeting words words
not numbers words are dumb words are
great uh yeah so I mean you can beat the
sort of campaign of the DLC and probably
about 10 hours okay um so it's pretty
substantial but there's also plenty of
stuff to just go and find that people
are already uncovering all these Easter
eggs all throughout the map so you just
kind of drive around and focus on
finding upgrades and crafting stuff and
discovering hidden areas things like
that so all things considered for
completionists like there's probably
like 20 hours of content to this DLC
which is substantial on a last question
here from Lord the l MV is parkour still
a big part of the game yeah actually so
I mean you spend a lot of time commuting
between locations but once you get to
those locations very often there is room
to kind of parkour and you can still
incorporate it in in combat like there
are boss encounters that happen in the
kind of enclosed areas and if you're
good at pork or you can use that to your
advantage to you know avoid dying and
co-op is still the thing by the way for
anybody that's wondering you can still
play all of this in coop your buddies
can actually jump in the back of your
buggy and like do you know right around
and buggy together it's great your very
own Chum Bucket yeah you can just kick
them off and keep driving as a
distraction right gonna have to outrun
the Bears get out run the guy is bare
zombie you know no yeah I like it and
that's it dying like the following it
says what's been out already but it's
out now on air on pc iguess on pc or
let's see pc xbox one and ps4 alright
yeah I forgot it was out on consoles
dansgame looks really good as well it's
not look it really does yeah and
actually the new setting allows it to
serve me
it's bright and yeah coastline and water
it's very nice Terry is Supergirl thanks
so much stuff absolutely talking